That was wonderful.
Thank you so much, Tom and Jenny Mundy for that.
And it's wonderful to see all the children we have here
and to hear what they were sharing about Jesus.
He was both king and savior.
Well, let's pray to him together
as we come to his words, his prayer.
Lord, we thank you that you are the savior of the world.
And Lord, thank you that you came to us
and Lord, I pray that you would help us all
to be ready to receive whatever you have for us this morning.
And Lord, thank you for each one of these children
who you have brought into the life of this church family.
And I pray for them as they continue on
to hear more about you, Lord,
that you would be speaking to them
and that you would guide those who are teaching them.
And Lord, as we open your word together now,
Lord, I pray that we would know you
speaking to us there and leading us
and providing us with what we need to glorify you
with the lives you've given us in Jesus' name, amen.
Amen, well, let's turn together to John chapter 10.
John chapter 10, we have been going through a series
on the I am statements of Jesus in the gospel of John.
So there are seven of these I am statements of Jesus.
This is where he's taking the name of God,
the foremost name of God used in the Old Testament
for himself because this is who he is.
He's saying I am who I am.
And each one of these statements
has a different picture attached to it
which tells us something more about who Jesus is.
And so we're coming to the third
and the fourth of these today.
So we're gonna take twice as long.
No, we're not gonna do that, don't worry.
But John chapter 10, you'll find two
of these I am statements there.
So let's listen carefully for these are the words of the Lord.
Truly, truly I say to you,
he who does not enter by the sheepfold
or enter the sheepfold by the door
but climbs in by another way,
that man is a thief and a robber.
He who enters by the door is the shepherd of the sheep.
Him the gatekeeper opens, the sheep hear his voice
and he calls his own sheep by name and leads them out.
When he has brought out all his own,
he goes before them and the sheep follow him
for they know his voice.
A stranger they will not follow
but they will flee from him
for they do not know the voice of strangers.
This figure of speech Jesus used with them
but they did not understand what he was saying to them.
Though Jesus again said to them,
truly, truly I say to you,
I am the door of the sheep.
All who came before me are thieves and robbers
but the sheep did not listen to them.
I am the door.
If anyone enters by me, he will be saved
and will go in and out and find pasture.
The thief comes only to steal and kill and destroy.
I came that they may have life and have it abundantly.
I am the good shepherd.
The good shepherd lays down his life for the sheep.
He who is a hired hand and not a shepherd
who does not own the sheep sees the wolf coming
and leaves the sheep and flees
and the wolf snatches them and scatters them.
He flees because he is a hired hand
and cares nothing for the sheep.
I am the good shepherd.
I know my own and my own know me.
Just as the father knows me and I know the father
and I lay down my life for the sheep
and I have other sheep that are not of this fold.
I must bring them also and they will listen to my voice.
So there will be one flock, one shepherd.
For this reason, the father loves me
because I lay down my life that I may take it up again.
No one takes it from me
but I lay it down of my own accord.
I have authority to lay it down
and I have authority to take it up again.
This charge I have received from my father.
This is the word of the Lord.
Well, many years ago when I was a teenager
I took a trip to the White House
and it was very interesting to go see it
but the thing that stands out the most in my mind
was when I met a none other than George W. Bush's dog
and they were taking the dogs,
two of them for a walk through the White House
and so I knelt down and like any dog would,
I guess they didn't know they were President's dog.
They came running over and one of them came up to me
and I got to pet.
I came in for his Barney, I think was the dog
and so I got to enjoy playing with the President's dog.
So that's my fun fact for the day about myself.
I remember walking then through another hallway on the tour
and there was another hallway where there were pictures
that lined all the way down.
There were all the different pets
that presidents have had through the years
and one of the most interesting pets
that a president ever had was Woodrow Wilson.
I don't know if you know your presidential pets
but he was fond of having sheep on the White House lawn
and it was during World War I
and the kind of idea he put forward was that they needed
to reduce the manpower needed to mow the lawn
so they got sheep instead to do it
and so they had presidential sheep.
So I mean there are worse places to be a sheep
in the world than the White House.
We even got this abundant supply of food
with all the acreage that is there.
You've got a staff team to look after you
and also I mean imagine the security.
There's no more secure sheep in the world
than sheep who were at the White House.
Unfortunately their shepherd and chief
did not get re-elected so they didn't last there very long
but that's another story.
This morning we're gonna look at sheep though
who have it far better than any sheep could have
at the White House and all the good that comes to them
but comes to them because of who their shepherd is.
Of course I'm speaking of the statement
we just read from Jesus where he says
I am the good shepherd.
The good shepherd lays down his life for the sheep.
So what is so good about the good shepherd?
That's what I want to ask this morning.
And so we're gonna look at,
it's been most of our time looking at who he is
and what he has done for us
and particularly what his kind of shepherd analogy here
tells us about that.
And then finally just briefly we're gonna consider
our response as we come to him in prayer.
So who is he telling us that he is
when he says I am the good shepherd?
Well last week when we looked at him being
the light of the world we were seeing a kind of
a contrast between darkness and light.
And now we're seeing a contrast here
between what you might say are bad shepherds
and the good shepherd.
So when he's saying I am the good shepherd
it's because he's been telling us about people
that you would not want to be your shepherd.
They are people Jesus refers to as the strangers.
Who are these strangers?
So he talks about the problem of the strangers.
What are they like?
Well in the immediate context they're religious leaders
that we looked at last week back in chapter nine.
So the kind of religious authorities of the day.
You may remember a man had been healed by Jesus
of his blindness so he's once blind now he can see.
When he openly confessed what had happened to him
and how it must point to the fact
that Jesus must really be from God.
He was met with resistance even ridicule
and they kicked him out of the synagogue, these leaders.
Now as we go into chapter 10,
these chapter divisions weren't kind of originally
in the Bible when it was written.
So it's the same crowd who are listening on
to what Jesus is now saying in chapter 10.
So you've got others who are listening
but it's also including the Pharisees
who had just mistreated this new disciple
for his faith in Christ.
These men and others like them are a danger
to the people of God.
He makes it clear in how he describes the strangers here.
He says they say that they are the ones
who are tasked with caring for God's people
but the reality is they are thieves,
they are robbers, they're even murderers.
So he uses the imagery of a sheepfold
to describe these false shepherds.
All right so he gives us a couple of characteristics.
One he says you can tell someone is a false shepherd
by the fact that they don't come through the gate.
They don't come through the door.
My family and I used to live in Burkina Faso, West Africa.
And I remember there was one day when we came home
and we came through the front door
and as we looked around,
stuff was just scattered all over the place.
And I mean more than usual.
I mean stuff was absolutely everywhere
and drawers were open and I just immediately
instinctively thought someone's broken in.
So I just, I ran through the house to see
if somebody was still there in the house.
I didn't see anybody.
But then when I looked at a small bathroom that we had,
I looked on the wall of the bathroom
and there on the wall was a footprint,
high up on the wall.
Somebody had managed to climb through this tiny window
that was there and had a muddy foot
that they used to prop themselves up on the wall.
Now we had lots of visitors into the house
but all of them, apart from one,
came through our front door.
Why did this guy come through this other way?
Because he was a thief.
That proved the fact that he was a thief
that he was coming another way.
So here Jesus says, verses say seven to nine.
Okay, so he talks about the door.
So you're saying, okay, well,
if the shepherd's true shepherd comes through the door,
well what is the door?
It says in verse seven.
Truly I say to you, I am the door of the sheep.
All who came before me are thieves and robbers
but the sheep did not listen to them.
I am the door.
If anyone enters in by me, he will be saved
and will go in and out and find pastor.
So you see there there's that kind of
another I am statement of Jesus
but it's related to what he's already saying.
Here's the idea.
Shepherd has this sheepfold he's looking after.
There's only one way to enter the sheepfold
and that's through the gate or through the door.
So you might say, well, okay,
if that's the analogy then is Jesus the shepherd
or is he the gate?
Like which one is he here?
What's been noted, there could be something to this
that sheep pens at the time would have
kind of one entrance way,
you know, when shepherds would be traveling with their sheep
they would bring their sheep into the pen
and they would kind of sit across the doorway
and so therefore they could be both shepherd and door
because he's obviously saying that he is both there.
He also talks about a gatekeeper
kind of opening the gate here.
So that may not be what he's saying here
but if he's mixing up his analogies
he's still doing it on purpose.
He is both the shepherd who looks after his sheep
but he's also the doorway to become
to enter into his sheepfold to know his salvation here.
All right, so you get the idea.
So Jesus alone is the way of salvation
and those who claim to be the leaders of God's people
and yet deny that Jesus is who he says he is
are in fact false shepherds.
As a true shepherd we'll be agreeing
with what Jesus says about himself
because he is the chief shepherd.
Now this still happens today.
There are people who claim to be leaders
of God's people, pastors or whatever.
They claim to speak on God's behalf
and yet say deny the uniqueness of Jesus
as the I am who alone can save.
There are churches and church leaders
who would deny the deity of Jesus
that he is truly God as well as truly man.
Sadly there are others who would deny the sufficiency
of Jesus to say well yes he is truly God
but when it comes to salvation like yes it's of his grace
but you've also gotta add in what you can do as well.
It's kind of a mixture of the two.
So they're denying what he is telling us
about him being the door here
as being the way of salvation himself.
You know there are secular versions of this as well.
You know if you want security
or you want to know in a kind of
an abundant life there are no shortage of people
who will offer you products that will be just a solution
or a way of life, this new trend
that you've got to take on board
so that you could know the safety
and abundance that they are offering.
But Jesus here alone is the one who saves
and supplies what we need in life and death.
Okay so they don't come in through the gates
so they're not on board with what Jesus says
about himself but also we see
that they don't truly care for the sheep.
So by their actions they are showing
that they are not true shepherds.
They might do some good things for sheep along the way
but in the end they put themselves before the sheep.
They may or may not deny Jesus with their words
but they deny him by their lives.
We see here that they take advantage of people.
So the true shepherd provides for his sheep
at great cost to himself
but the false shepherds are described as thieves.
They're thieves, they're robbers.
They, instead of caring for the sheep
they use the sheep to care for themselves
and to satisfy their own desires.
So instead of being driven by a love of God
and a love for his people
they're driven by a love of something else.
They're satisfying their own desire.
It could be chasing after power or prestige
or a paycheck.
They want something else and these people
are a means to get what they're truly after.
So they use people instead of loving them
and caring for them.
So they're there to take advantage of the sheep.
You know that can happen in parts of the world
where the church is marginalized or even persecuted
but there's a unique danger I think in a culture
which has a kind of professionalized Christianity.
We have a large Christian population in the US
and it's also a culture that happens to idolize
things like impressiveness or celebrity
or how much you have or having the newest thing
or whatever it is.
Let's not kid ourselves that this can also happen
in the life of the church
where people use the people of God to profit
to get whatever it is they're really after.
And that can happen in places where in outright
I say prosperity gospel is preached
where people just flaunt their wealth or whatever
and they say they want you to sow a seed of faith
so that you can know the blessing that they have as well.
And so you see that in cases like this
but there are also other subtle cases as well.
But you know even just one person leading another
can do so more out of a desire
for what they are aiming to get out of that person
than a desire to love and serve them well.
This is not just the case for somebody
with a big public profile.
This can be how we just treat one another.
So loving someone, we use them to get what we are truly after.
That's not what the shepherd does.
The take advantage of people but after taking advantage of them
we look they abandon them.
So in verse 12, Jesus talks about people being hired hands.
But these are people who look after the sheep
but once again they're primarily motivated
by the money rather than care for the sheep.
They may even be doing a good work
but it's mostly a job to them.
How do we know that that's what's motivating them?
Well when a wolf turns up and they are in danger
their instinct is to abandon the sheep
because they're no longer gonna get something out of it.
It's gonna cost them something.
So if they're there for what they can get out of it
and all of a sudden it costs them something, they leave.
But they're there to take advantage
than they abandon the sheep at the end.
So if you're involved in something primarily
for what you're gonna get out of it
when it becomes costly, you leave.
So that's what they do.
That's not what Jesus does.
More about that in a second.
So you see the problem of these strangers here.
You see the kind of the negative side
but we also see the promise of the shepherd.
So what Jesus is saying here
isn't just a great analogy for who he is
or what he is like.
He's not just pulling this idea out of the air.
Same with all the I am statements
but the shepherd too.
Because the Old Testament, the word of God
leading up to this point,
it's full of references to sheep and to shepherds.
This language is, for example,
used as a metaphor for leaders.
But these leaders, these shepherds
were ultimately pointing to God
as being the good shepherd.
So for example, Jacob,
whose name was later changed to Israel.
He is described as being a shepherd.
I guess he looked after sheep.
So then you get to the end of his life
in Genesis chapter 48.
He says that all along throughout his life
it is God who has been his shepherd.
Right, so he was a leader and a shepherd
but God has been his shepherd.
When the future king, David is found,
where is he found?
He's found looking after sheep.
Right, so he is a shepherd.
And so this shepherd then becomes the king of God's people
but then he writes in Psalm 23, you know it.
The Lord is my shepherd.
I shall not want.
So he's king, King David.
But he knows that there's a greater king,
a greater shepherd, the Lord.
And you get to a passage like Ezekiel 34.
We're not gonna camp out in that one today
but if I could encourage you to read
any other passage this week connected with this,
I would say open your Bible to Ezekiel 34
and just read John 10 and Ezekiel 34
beside one another.
And you could see that they are just alike
because you have these leaders in Israel
who are called to be under shepherds
to shepherd God's people.
And yet, like we just saw, they were using God's people.
They were instead of caring for the sheep,
they were consuming the sheep.
But the Lord says that he, the answer to this
is that he tells the shepherd what they're doing
and how wrong it is.
But he says that there's coming a day when he himself,
the Lord himself will be the shepherd of his people.
And then he talks about how he is going
to shepherd his people.
He is going to send another David,
a true and better David
who is going to be the final shepherd of his people.
He's gonna gather and save and lead the people of God.
You have this picture of this final shepherd who's coming.
So you've got this jewel thing happening.
The Lord is saying, I am the shepherd of my people.
And he also says, and I'm gonna send this shepherd
who's going to shepherd my people.
So both of those things are true at the same time.
How can that be?
What's fulfilled in the person of Jesus?
Jesus here is saying, that is me.
I am the one who promised to be the shepherd of my people.
I am the good shepherd.
I've come to gather my sheep,
to save them to be their true final shepherd king.
This is speaking then,
when Jesus says I am the good shepherd,
what's it telling us about him?
One is it speaking of his sovereignty.
He is the king of kings who leads his people.
It also speaks of his goodness.
So he deeply cares for his people.
So in his love, he desires our good.
And in his power, he is able to bring about everything
that he desires for us.
The Christian, this is the same Jesus.
Name's shepherd who cares for you.
He's not a shepherd who wants to care for you, but can't.
Neither is he a shepherd who can, but wants.
He's the good shepherd.
So that's who he is, but what does he do here?
You see it not only in who he is, but what he does.
He does the work of a shepherd to,
before we moved here,
we promised the kids that we'd get a dog.
Man, we love our dog.
He's wonderful.
He's a golden retriever,
but he was more work than we anticipated.
And I don't know if you've ever got a puppy before.
I thought I had a puppy once.
I was five years old at the time.
So I don't particularly remember how hard the work was,
but we looked after him.
There were all the, you know, taking him on walks
and all the visits to the vet and potty training
and all the rest.
So we had to put the work in here.
So if that's the case with just looking after a dog,
which maybe you can identify with your pets
or whatever, looking after them,
it must be much harder work to be a shepherd,
to be a farmer or something like that.
So Jesus is using this analogy
in a way that's not just telling us about who he is,
but the work that he came to do.
There's a specific work that's shepherding,
a specific kind of shepherding he is doing.
So his affection as shepherd is seen
in the actions that he takes.
So what does he do?
What's his work?
Well, he takes care of the sheep.
They have the obvious.
He cares for them.
All right, so the thieves take,
but he gives the hired hand, flees.
Jesus is faithful.
He stays.
Good shepherd is willing to do whatever it takes
to take care of his sheep.
How does he care for them?
Well, one couple of ways here.
He lays down his life for the sheep.
He repeats that here,
I'm gonna lay down my life for the sheep.
What does that mean?
He lays down his life for me.
So he dies for the sheep.
One is just showing that he died willingly when he says,
I'm going to lay down my life for the sheep.
Now make a mistake about it.
This is the, we're thinking about Palm Sunday.
The King of Glory is the one who is entering Jerusalem.
And by the way, his kingly authority
isn't just kind of alluded to here
by talking about being the shepherd.
He speaks about his authority specifically in verse 18,
but he uses his authority, his kingly authority
in a very specific way.
He says, I have authority to lay it down,
to lay my life down and have authority to take it up again.
But here's how the king uses his authority
to willingly lay down his life for us.
To rise again as our shepherd king.
So he dies willingly.
But he also, when he says,
I'm laying down my life for you,
we see that he dies sacrificially.
That we laid down his life for the sheep.
The four in the place of.
Right, so the shepherd lays down his life
as a sacrificial lamb.
But his death doesn't just prove his love in that,
like I'd be willing to do anything for you,
even to die to show you how much I love you.
In his death, he is actually providing salvation.
Like that is the actual need here.
He needs to die in our place.
And so he willingly lays down his life as a sacrifice
in the place of his sheep.
You see death is coming our way,
the wolf is coming our way, so to speak.
He lays down his life to save us.
How amazing is that is to think
that the king would lay down his life for us,
that a shepherd would lay down his life for the sheep.
There's a big difference between shepherd and sheep.
The one, the king of glory.
He's willing to die for us.
Amazing.
This is what we're remembering on Palm Sunday,
that he's both the king.
He's going to Jerusalem.
He knows where he is heading for.
He's heading for the cross,
where he will willingly die for us.
You know, if he was willing to die for us,
to take our sin upon himself,
to die the death that we deserve,
then we can trust him with anything.
If he'd be willing to do that for us,
what could we not trust him with?
So he lays down his life for us,
but he also looks after us.
You know, he provides this great thing
by laying down his life,
we could trust that God with him
will freely give us all things.
We read in Romans chapter eight.
Here we see that through his death
we are given eternal life.
That eternal life doesn't begin just someday.
It begins now.
So he provides for us by being with us
throughout our lives,
giving us all that we need to live the life
that he has made us for to glorify him.
So he's leading his sheep in good pastures now.
So we can say even now,
if we know Jesus leading us as our shepherd,
the one who loves us that much,
being present with us,
if we know him leading us forward,
we can say, I shall not want.
We can say, he makes me lie down in green pastures.
He leads me beside still waters.
He is the shepherd of Psalm 23.
So we may not always understand
what God is doing in our lives,
but whatever happens,
we can rest in the fact that the one who leads us
was willing to lay down his life for us.
This is the one who is present with us.
This is the one who is feeding us with his word.
We can rest in him.
We can say with David,
even though I walk through the valley
of the shadow of death,
if everything were to be taken away from me,
I will fear no evil.
You are with me.
The shepherd cares for his sheep,
his goodness, his mercy,
following us all the days of our lives.
We will dwell in the house of the Lord forever.
What does he do?
He cares for his sheep,
but also he calls his sheep.
You see this repeatedly in our text.
So verse three,
the sheep hear his voice
and he calls his own sheep by name
and he leads them out.
The sheep hear his voice
when he is calling out to them.
How can you know that you are among those
that are his sheep?
Well, his sheep are those who respond to his call.
A few things about his call.
One, his call is global.
Why would I say that?
Verse 16, he says to the people of Israel here,
he's gathering with them in a particular context
and he's speaking in a way that calls back
to all those images and promises in the Old Testament.
But he's saying,
and I have sheep that are not of this fold,
and I must bring them also.
They will listen to my voice.
So there will be one flock and one shepherd.
In other words, he's not just calling people
in that locality at that time.
His call as the shepherd is going to go out
across the world.
He has a global flock.
In other words, that includes us.
This wonderful promise here.
So it's a global call.
He calls to people everywhere.
But also his call is effectual.
Let's say it that way.
So this global call is an effectual call.
What I mean?
So there's a sense in which his call is universal.
It's to whoever will come.
So Jesus invites whoever will come to him to come to him.
And those who come to him will be saved.
But there's another layer of his call
that the passage speaks of here.
Notice how confidently he speaks about his sheep.
He says his sheep will hear his voice.
They will hear his voice.
So you see it again in verse 27.
My sheep hear my voice and I know them
and they follow me.
You go back to verse 16 when he talks about other sheep
not being of this fold,
but being part of that global fold.
He says, and they will listen to my voice.
So there will be one flock and one shepherd.
So there's a certainty by which he speaks here.
But the reason they respond in faith to his call
is because they have been marked out as his sheep.
This is similar to what Jesus already said
back in John chapter six in verse 37.
Right after he said, I am the bread of life.
Whoever comes to me will never hunger.
Whoever believes in me will never thirst.
Well, and then in John 6, 37,
he says all that the Father gives to me will come to me.
All right, so there's a will there,
a definite coming that happens in response to his call.
So in verse 26 of our own passage,
what does he say to people who do not believe?
He says, but you do not believe
because you are not among my sheep.
My sheep hear my voice.
That doesn't mean that if anybody ever resists
the call to believe the gospel,
or that if they don't believe in Jesus
the first time they hear about him, that that is it.
That's not what Jesus is saying here at all.
Where all of us probably need to hear the gospel
multiple times repeated over and over again,
being called to believe.
But ultimately, if we believe
is because he's gathered us as his sheep.
So it's a demonstration.
Our faith in Jesus is demonstrating
that we are part of his sheepfold.
So in the book of Acts, for example,
Acts chapter 13 in verse 48 says this,
so the gospel is being preached to Gentiles,
to sheep who are not of this fold.
And it says, when the Gentiles heard this,
they began rejoicing and glorifying the word of the Lord.
And hear this,
and as many as were appointed unto eternal life believed.
Let's clear there, his sheep hear his voice
those who are appointed to eternal life believe.
So this invitation to come to Christ
and know him as your shepherd is open to anyone
who will turn from their sin and put their trust in him.
But in the end, we come because he makes us his own.
He makes us his sheep.
So his call is effectual,
but also his call is personal too.
So this is not just a theological concept.
We can get kind of distracted over thinking about
that his call being effectual
and how that relates to believing and all the rest.
But listen, this is personal what he is saying here.
He calls his sheep by name.
Verse three, the sheep hear his voice.
He calls his own sheep by name and leads them out.
There's a personal care for the sheep here.
I don't know what your favorite documentary
about penguins is,
but mine is the March of the Penguins.
I don't know if you've seen that.
Morgan Freeman narrates, it's really good.
And it's a really fascinating documentary,
I promise about the harrowing lives of emperor penguins
in Antarctica, particularly as they raise their young.
And so they have this baby chick
and the mother and dad,
just summarizing this really quick,
they kind of take turns looking after this newborn baby.
And one of them has to go and get food.
And then they'll be out for days and weeks on end
and then they come back.
But when they come back to feed this baby chick,
they are coming back to thousands and thousands
of emperor penguins who all look alike
and who all sound alike and they're all just squalking
and just whatever they do.
I don't know what a penguin does to they squawk.
They're making this loud noise and you think,
well, how in the world are they gonna find
which one belongs to them?
Cause they all look the same.
And the answer is that each one of them,
it sounds the same to us,
but each one of them has a unique vocal signature
that almost works like a kind of unaudible fingerprint.
And so it's amazing that these penguins
can recognize the one that belongs to them by the voice.
They can look through all of it and say, well, that is,
that's mine, that's the one that I belong to.
That's my baby there.
And here we see this,
the Lord knows the one who is his own.
So we live in this world with all these dangers
and all these many voices calling for our attention,
voices that would lead us astray
and yet in the midst of it all,
the Lord knows those who are his own,
calls out to them, they hear his voice
and they follow.
Amazing, it's a personal call to know Jesus as your shepherds
to hear him calling your name.
There's relationship here.
He cares for us and he calls us.
And lastly, he keeps us.
He keeps his sheep.
So verse 28 and 29,
you don't have it in your worship guides, sorry,
but it's there in John chapter 10.
He says, I give them eternal life
and they will never perish
and no one will snatch them out of my hands.
My Father who has given them to me is greater than all
and no one is able to snatch them out of my Father's hand.
So those whom the Lord saves brings into his fold,
he keeps, right?
He looks after them.
He's not gonna let them go.
He's not gonna lose any one of them.
He holds us in his hands
and we're also held in the hands of the Father.
We have eternal life.
If it's eternal, it never ends.
For given eternal life now, that's not gonna stop.
Whereas Paul says in Romans 8,
we might be counted as sheep for the slaughter.
And all these things we are more than conquerors
through him who loves us.
Nothing in all of creation is able to separate us
from the love of God in Christ Jesus.
We are secure eternally in his love.
Why is that the case?
Because the lamb down his life for the sheep,
that is who is reigning as our shepherd.
He reigns forever.
I love Revelation chapter seven and verse 17.
So listen to what it says here,
throwing together the theme of Jesus laying down his life
as a lamb and yet being our shepherd.
Revelation 7, 17 says this,
is for the lamb in the midst of the throne.
This is what we have to look forward to.
The lamb in the midst of the throne will be their shepherd
and he will guide them to springs of living water
and will wipe away every tear from their eyes.
We will know the care of our shepherd forever.
On that day, all sorrow, all sickness, death,
all the brokenness in the world will be gone.
We will know the care of our shepherd forever.
But the question is, how are you responding
to the voice of the shepherd today?
Just three very brief things just to help us to think
through what we're gonna pray about here in a moment.
How are you responding to the voice of the shepherd?
One, have you come to him by faith?
He laid down his life for us.
The way we know him as our shepherd,
by turning away from our sin, putting our faith in him.
Do you hear him calling your voice,
inviting you to know him as your shepherd?
Do you hear the call of his voice?
Come, put your faith in Jesus.
The other thing is,
are you resting in his care as your shepherd today?
So there's many of us here, if not most of us,
who have come to him and said, yes, he is my shepherd.
One thing to say that, to know that,
nothing to rest in his sovereign care for us.
Maybe we find ourselves looking to other false shepherds
who promise safety that we're longing for,
or the satisfaction that we're longing for.
Maybe we live in the fear of what we're going to do without.
Whatever concerns you have that you're feeling deeply
this morning, or you felt this past week,
or you're worried about for the week ahead, know this,
you can rest in the sovereign care of your shepherd king.
You can rest in the sovereign care of your shepherd king.
He's got it, he loves you.
And then lastly, learn to follow him as your shepherd king.
His sheep follow him, follow where he is leading.
Well, where is he leading us?
He's leading us on paths of righteousness for his name's sake.
Beking to us in his word,
showing us in the way we should go,
shaping us into his likeness.
He might love others the way we have been loved by him.
Whatever we need this morning,
shepherd is ready to supply it.
Let's come to him in prayer.
Take just a moment where we're sat.
He meant whatever the Lord draws to your mind to him.
He is one.
Well, thank you so much.
You are the good shepherd.
Lord, I pray that you would help us to pray
and to praise you this week as our good shepherd.
I pray that we would know the depths of our souls,
that if we know you as our shepherd,
we can also say, I shall not want.
But I pray that you would help us
to respond to your call,
that we will put our trust in you,
knowing that you will lead us.
And that you will care for us
and supply all that we need.
That you will bring us one day to be with you,
that we might know your shepherd.